imagine it's the year 2004.
this is phil phil's looking to release a
book and set up a blog
he's sure that he'd be successful but
he's only worried about
one thing he doesn't know how to ensure
that his book reaches the right target
audience
who could enjoy his book during that
period of time however
there were only a few forms of
advertisement available like
print ads billboards radio direct mail
direct sales and the television all of
these options were pretty expensive
their effectiveness couldn't be
accurately determined and they didn't
let him advertise his content
to the appropriate audience phil's book
would never
find the audience it deserved now let's
have a look at the same scenario in the
present day
alongside traditional forms of
advertising phil would have access to
digital marketing
a form of marketing that's a lot more
lucrative inexpensive
and configurable marketing that would
enable marketers to advertise their
audience digitally using channels like
search engines
websites social media platforms emails
etc among these types social media
marketing
cop feels eye social media marketing
would give phil the opportunity to take
advantage of social media
platforms to advertise his content to a
highly targeted audience
it would help more people learn about
his book increase the interaction with
his audience
it's relatively inexpensive unless he
goes into advertising
and will help him get marketplace
insights that might help in
understanding his audience preferences
better
phil started by taking up a
certification to learn about social
media marketing
since he was already familiar with the
concept of social media marketing
his next step was to learn about the
different types of content he could post
on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that phil could post would be
images text posts polls and videos
but over time phil began to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content
phil needed to advertise his content for
that
he would need to use the advertising
options provided by the social media
platforms like facebook
instagram youtube linkedin and twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options
like image ads these ads involve the use
of single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text
they also have a call to action that
encourages user interaction
phil could use images from his book
advertise websites that
sell his book and more then there are
text and post ads
these ads could advertise posts or
excerpts from phil's blog or his book
further garnering interest from an
interesting audience
he could also use video ads phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertise his books
phil could also use lead ads through
which he could collect information from
users who are interested in a weekly
newsletter or regular updates from his
blog
but that wasn't the only thing phil
could do with social media platforms
he could create a brand for himself and
drive audience interest to it
engage with them create an identity
engage with content
finding content that works for him
social media platforms also allowed him
the opportunity to target audiences
based on demographics like their age
location
gender and much more and in time phil
began to see an increase in the number
of viewers coming to his social media
page
and by extension his blog he also saw an
increase in the number of people who
bought his book
greatly increasing his audience here are
some things he learned
one to set goals that were quantitative
smart
and follow a constant deadline two to
understand his audience by engaging
and connecting with them three to set up
a social media calendar to plan
competitions
polls surveys videos and more
four using tools like buzzsumo ifttt
buffer and more for lead generation
creating email lists
setting buyer personas and more
to perform visual storytelling with the
help of images and videos
but how did phil get so good at social
media marketing
before we find the answer to that
question let's have a look at a quiz
what can you do with social media
marketing a
create a brand for yourself b engage
with an audience
c target users based on demographics
d all of the above choose the right
answer and have a chance to win an
amazon voucher
now back to our question how did phil
get so
good at social media marketing phil had
taken up simply learn's digital
marketing course
it was thanks to this course that phil
had the skills and training to get good
at social media marketing
and now you can too by clicking on the
top right corner
and with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
channel and to click on the bell icon
for more on the latest technologies and
trends
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simplylearn
you